we're never going to eliminate
a great player like bud dupree because
we don't know what bud's market is and
but doesn't know what his market is
at this point i think that's pretty
it's pretty common for
not only our free agents but the whole
free agency
group until we get a solid cap number
we don't know and we just have to adjust
and
and know that he might be a possibility
he might not be
only time will tell with that but we'd
love to be able to keep a button free
because
bud's a special player but bud and tj
together are as a special group
oh he had to tell did you see the tell
he might be a possibility you see that
his hands were down the whole time until
he says he might be a possibility and he
scratches his face that means he's not a
possibility that's my read on it miles
and you know i feel bad for bud dupree
in his franchise tag year tears his acl
he's not going to get a multi-year
contract he's not going to get the kind
of money that he would have gotten he's
not going to get the payday that he
deserved and that's unfortunate he's
going to have to go somewhere for one
year
and try to lay the foundation to cash in
i don't think the steelers are going to
bring him back unless
he just finds nothing out there and they
can get him for a bargain type of a
contract that clearly they won't use the
franchise tag again they'd have to give
him a 20 raise he's still rehabbing that
acl tear it's just a it's just a very
unfortunate situation but when kevin
colbert scratches his face as he says he
might be a possibility
that tells me
he is not a possibility
yeah mike i agree with you i just don't
feel like there's a need for him to be
back anymore they have alex high smith i
think he played pretty darn well down
the stretch and he's somebody that i
think can grow and develop for them on
the steelers defense so it's just really
unfortunate for bud dupree now because
he's a guy that had 11 and a half sacks
in 2019 he was on pace to probably
exceed that he had eight he had eight
sacks through 11 games um in 2020 so
when he's playing for ostensibly that
big multi-year contract and then he
tears his acl it's just a really
unfortunate situation because now you
just really have no idea what his market
is kevin colbert's totally right there
what is the market for a guy like that
who you know is effective when healthy
but you just simply don't know exactly
what he's going to be coming off of that
injury and
people recover from that injury much
much better than they ever did even a
few years ago at this point it's still a
little bit of a risk there for any team
that wants to get after him mike
and one of the realities for the
steelers the past 30 years ever since
free agency came to be
they they let these pass rushing
linebackers go all the time all the time
find another we'll find another we'll
find another and they're never going to
break the bank and this is one where you
can't break the bank because you just
don't know the salary cap issue
notwithstanding that's part of it but
also the health issue so i expect duprey
to be somewhere else and he could be one
of these guys who joins the super team
and wins the super bowl somewhere else
in 2021 miles
yeah he could be and i think that he
could be a really productive player for
one of these teams like that and if on
any team that has a need at pass rusher
i would be going after bud dupree for a
low offer
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports